Hey....
it's dangerous here
Go, fly...
Far away...
...from here.
Whoever destroys the machine gun
will become the next warrior
The armored titan will be one of us!!
I think I understand you now.
You wanted to save the world
Right?
Shut up...
Why?...
Why can't you let me die?
From the appearance of the founder Ymir to the present day
The Titans have taken many lives
But in recent years
That peace has been taken away!!
Because someone has stole the founding titan inside the island of paradis!
His name is...
Eren Yeager!!
An now I proclaim "Fight"
To the enemy forces of Paradis
a declaration of war!
Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this
is going to be my attack on Titan season 4
trailer for the final season they're
going all the way through the final arc
and the manga so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos I got a lot of requests to do
a video for this and they actually show
quite a bit from the very recent manga
stuff in this so if you're wondering how
they were able to get all this footage
in if they're not completely done
animating the season it's because a lot
of the animation in the trailer was made
separate from the actual episodes so the
animation for the actual final episodes
might look a little bit different than
the way they look in the scenes of the
trailer but all the scenes in the
trailer will be stuff that they cover
during the final season and they show a
bunch of stuff here the rest of the
original 9 Titans there's a couple new
ones that we're seeing for the first
time including the founding Titan I know
there's a bunch of questions about
what's going on with that they even full
blown to show us the coordinate so if
you're not really familiar with what's
going on with that I'll try to explain
in his non spoilery away as possible
because this is basically everything
through the end of the story season 4
will be 12 episodes total so they're
obviously going to be compressing a lot of
the story where we left off in season 3
episode 22 in the finale that's
basically going to be the beginning of the
Majerle arc so they'll cover that pretty
quickly and then you have the war for
paradis arc which is basically the final
arc and the manga the marlee arc picks
up at the end of season 3 episode 22
where they find the coastline and
they're all playing around but then they
realize that this is where all the Eldian
exiles are brought and then
forcibly turned into titans and set
loose because basically Paradise Island
is a prison island where they send all
the exiled but the Majerle arc itself is
all about the Marlins realizing through
their war with the Middle East Allied
forces that even though Majerle controls
a number of the special Titans in the
Titan shifters their special Titans
themselves aren't enough to win wars as
military technology continues to evolve
they believe that the only thing that's
going to guarantee their supremacy is
the power of the founding Titan but that
power leads them to Paradise Island
so obviously this gets involved in
Aaron's story and his family's history
in season 3 episode 22 he has that
vision learning a little bit about his
connection to the Eldian royal family
when historia touches him so if you
jumped off the
series there have been a number of
really big reveals about the history of
Aaron's family how he came into
possession of the attack Titan how he
came into the possession of the founding
titan in what the coordinate is and what
this grand plan is because there's a lot
of competing agendas with different
forces on the show so as at the end of
season 3 and going into season 4 there
are going to be a couple of time jumps they
kind of deal with that at the end of
season 3 in the finale where they
basically say six months have gone by
but as the finale Christa's true
identity has been revealed as historia
Reis lasts or one of the last remaining
members of the Eldian royal family
technically there are a couple other
royal bloodline members out there
because that sort of gets into who can
control the power of the Titans how the
power of the founding Titan works she
decides to reveal the secret of the
Titans to everyone and naturally
everybody freaks out the funny thing
about this is that if you were watching
the intros for pretty much the last
couple of seasons they'd tell you the
history of the Titans of the history of
the world in those intros if you kind of
know what's going on the whole deal with
the vision that Aaron gets is that he's
actually seeing a vision of the
fritzsche royal family we learned about
Aaron's father's history in Marley he
actually infiltrated Marley seeking to
gain the power of the founding Titan
from the Reese family eventually he
started a relationship with Dana Fritz
one of the royal family members they had
a child together that became Zeke their
first child who's Aaron's half-brother
then later he was exiled was able to
steal the power of the founding Titan
for himself while he contained the power
of the attack Titan then later he starts
another family with Aaron's mother then
more recently Aaron winds up eating his
father when he's in a pure Titan form
and gains the power to the founding
Titan that way so this huge final arc of
the series is all about what Aaron is
going to do with the power of the
founding Titan now I'll talk about that
in a second because it has some really
cool powers beyond those of the other
Titans but in this trailer you see most
of the other Titans the new ones are the
jaw tightened the hammer tight and I'll
explain those in a second but you also
see the cart Titan with all the weapons
and the guns the Beast Titan again
because that's Zeke but then you've also
see Annie come back in her chrysalis no
spoilers for who this jaw Titan is but
as the name implies the jaw Titan
possesses incredible biting and crushing
strength with its jaws in its nails it's
really good as a siege weapon for say
tearing walls apart and for crushing
other Titans the Warhammer
actually has the ability to create other
structures using the hardened Titan
flesh which has you pretty useful no
spoilers for who possesses the power of
the hammer Titan but that'll be a big
part of the Marley Arc so I'm assuming
they're going to cover that during the
first half of the season all the physics
in the history and the mechanics of how
the founding Titan work are actually
pretty complicated there's a lot of
complications for what your bloodline is
and who can control it at what time and
how it's being controlled and what you
can use it for but it's a very Lord of
the Rings Ring of Power situation one
ring to rule them all the founding Titan
is able to control all the other Titans
to alter their Titan forms change their
size their physiology and the person who
is currently in possession or
controlling the founding Titan can use
it to telepathically communicate with
everyone that is genetically a subject
of Amir you can even use the power of
the founding Titan to alter everyone's
memories which actually you find out
happened in the past
that's why Marley wants to get their
hands on it so badly because it's a god
tier Titan this shot here for instance
though is the coordinate the founding
Titan is also referred to as the
coordinate where all paths of all
subjects of a mirror and the Titans
cross so it's sort of this focal point
across time space in the sort of
metaphysical way between all these
people that are connected through this
bloodline of a mirror going back
centuries sort of connections between
all these different people but this is
also known as the unknown land it's just
the metaphysical place where this all
exists but if you're a big fan of
history and attack on Titan because it
goes so deep one of the cool things
about this final arc is that you do get
the full explainer for what happened
with Amir the origin of the Titans and
what happened with the first king fritz
you learn why it is that people hated
the Eldians
so much because they were kind of
terrible people you also get a lot of
Amir's personal history here too so it's
actually really cool you'll learn about
how she actually originally gained the
power of the very first Titan of the
founding tightened around 2,000 years
ago before the king learned of her power
she was actually being attacked she ran
into this giant tree didn't realize
there was a sinkhole fell into this
giant pool infused with a very spine
like structure that actually gave her
the power of the founding Titan so
that's kind of what you're seeing here
you're getting a little bit
tree in the trailer Amir was the first
person to obtain the power of the Titans
but she became enslaved to the Eldian
king who just abused her power and then
eventually trapped her inside the
coordinate in the unknown land and used
her power to control all the other
Titans until thousands of years ago you
have the great Titan war and the Eldian
king and the rest of his people are
exiled to Paradis Island and then they
create the walls and then erase
everyone's memories so they don't
remember everything in order to use the
power of the founding Titan technically
you have to be a member of the royal
family though either from the fritz of
the Reese family that's how historian
Reese is connected to the founding Titan
but if the founding Titan is inherited
by someone outside the royal family like
Eren Yeager here the power can still be
used if the inheritor like Eren is in
physical contact with a Titan with royal
blood that's how he's able to have this
giant flashback and see her memories
because he contains the power of the
founding Titan when he's doing this once
they do decide what the actual release
date is going to be that's probably when
they'll release another big trailer so
I'll try to do another video when that
happens but because the Rick and Morty
season 4 finale is tomorrow click here
for my Rick and Morty finale trailer
video and click here for my brand new
Marvel Wolverine deleted scene video
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe I'll see you guys tonight!